Bernie Sanders cannot get a break after
2016 when he was essentially hosed by
the DNC and dismissed by the media this
was supposed to be his time then in Iowa
despite getting the most votes he ended
up with fewer delegates than P Budaj
giving the former mayor a rosy press
narrative going into New Hampshire but
even when Bernie pulled out a clear
victory in New Hampshire it's still not
even treated like a win the big winner
last night
could be Mayor Bloomberg Budaj and club
would shower and Biden split the
moderate vote with their combined
percentage overwhelming that of Sanders
we go to moderate candidate who come out
at this and very strong shape tonight
again they'll support anybody except the
guy who actually won but the reason is
obvious the establishment and the elites
don't want the curmudgeon socialist
Bernie Sanders to run away with the
nomination and because what would that
do that would upend their comfy if
ineffective status quo now Joe Biden was
supposed to stop him but we feel that
need to stop him from embarrassing
himself call the caregiver the man
should be doing some age-appropriate
group activities that will keep his mind
active
but campaigning shouldn't be one of them
for poor old Biden now given all this we
are the party apparatus and media
toady's going to turn to now to the
person whom I dubbed last winter as the
left's new it boy the newest darling of
journalists Hollywood errs and Metro
lefties is the mayor of South Bend
Indiana the coastal elites I don't think
they've ever loved a Midwestern ER as
much as they loved Pete he's a charmer
well he looked at the dashing in his
army fatigues too right I mean a policy
wonk a Harvard guy rose color yet he's
very modest he's a modern-day
Renaissance man
god bless people judge but he kind of
talks at the level of Mister Rogers and
with that sort of Pope
composure employees and he just did it
up here on the stage enhancements speaks
in perfect sentences it's impressive
he's an amazing human being doesn't Pete
just make you all feel inadequate and
there's more
Pete evolves to talk about growing as a
candidate I was mayor at South Bend
Indiana and now is you know Co
frontrunner perhaps for the Democratic
nomination wait cold front runner is
that what they said well I guess
technically maybe you could say that but
he's polling 13 points behind Bernie
Sanders nationally not to mention that
in the next two nominating contests
Nevada in South Carolina he's at 7% and
5.5 percent respectively we needed to
get the point 5 percent but what he
lacks in popularity on Main Street come
on Pete makes up for it more than that
on Wall Street let's face it they want a
hedge against Bernie and they know Pete
will be putty in the hands of someone
like president gee and that's good for
the globalists at first glance buta
judge seems to have a really pretty good
political resume right he's a former
small town my era Army reservist Rhodes
scholar and the first gay presidential
candidate but while he may be a first
like Obama Obama had both charisma and E
at least he had been a senator Buddha
judge really is kind of a bland
composite of a lot of things but with
zero relevant experience the only thing
he's ever run South Bend Indiana is a
crime ridden mess violent crime surged
70 percent during his time as mayor
while the country as a whole
saw a crime fall by two percent in that
same time frame but pay no attention to
the facts just keep hinting that he's
like Obama except gay and white there's
no question at all that Pete Buddha
judge is occupying a bit of that Obama
Lane reminds me a little bit of early
Obama in the campaign like Barack Obama
before him Pete is young
inspiring he brings fresh ideas to the
table well unlike Obama who could
inspire with his supporters with soaring
rhetoric number that 2004 DNC speech and
grand idealism when Buddha judge tries
to make profound statements he just ends
up sounding like an idiot it is time to
walk away from the politics of the past
and toward something totally different
by this time it's not just about winning
an election it's about winning an era
the shape of our democracy is the issue
that affects every other issue the
taking out a bad guy is not a good idea
if you do not know what you were doing
Wow
deep for self-absorbed liberals Budaj
edge though it's kind of like an ink
swatch he's a Rorschach test they read
into him what they want to see even if
it's not there they're seething hatred
of all things Trump has turned otherwise
reasonably intelligent Democrats into
puddles of goo looking for their next
crush but like all shallow crushes this
one too will end up disappointing once
you get past the butterflies and that's
the angle